[Music]
so here is our model of the entire Giza
necropolis you'll see we've had to
remove modern structures and excavators
debris dumps we studied the Nile and we
had to move it much closer to the Giza
pyramids because in antiquity the Nile
did flow closer and we've tried to
rebuild each and every structure not all
of them are yet in the level of detail
that we would like but we have most of
them in place the Sphinx is probably the
most accurate reconstruction that has
been attempted so far and you can see
the central field master bus the eastern
cemetery the West all of the major
components in place this is now the
centralized study tool and research tool
and as we link all these diverse data we
hope that you will eventually be able to
navigate anywhere you want to go click
on anything that grabs your interest and
up will pop the related diverse
information that extends to the Sphinx
as well and what's fascinating about
this type of 3d visualization is it
calls up questions that you may not have
considered in more traditional avenues
so for example color on the Sphinx was
the Sphinx entirely painted was just the
head painted we don't have enough
surviving exterior blocks to really come
to a secure conclusion about that so we
study what we can and we have to move
forward with the best information that
we have at the time this comparison
image of our 3d model shows you two
possibilities above just the head and
the Nemus head cloth is painted down
below the entire body is painted in the
reddish-brown reserved for male figures
what do you think another important
aspect of visualization is of course the
z-axis time so we can look at Giza when
everything is complete we can look at
Giza at the very beginnings when the
Great Pyramid is just starting to rise
and in this video snippet you can see
the quarry where a lot of the core
blocks are being cut for the Great
Pyramid complex
we'll look at some of these in more
detail in other sections of this module
and other modules this photo shows the
pyramid temple of Khafre builder of
the second pyramid in today's a rather
ruinous state and then the computer
model restores it all this is based on
our study of the architectural features
of royal pyramid complexes from the old
kingdom and to date it's the best
reconstruction that we've been able to
produce seated statues of Khafre
probably adorned at the courtyard and in
the image you can see the model bark
being brought into one of the chambers
this allows us to experiment with the
size of this bark or boat carrying a
statue of the king and whether it's big
enough or small enough to actually fit
between the doors of the temple here is
a still rendering from the Sphinx area
and the Sphinx temple in front of it and
then adjacent to it the Khafre Valley
temple and you'll notice the harbor
coming right up close to the entrance to
the temple inside khafre's valley temple
there are emplacements little slots in
the floor that were meant to hold seated
statues of the king here again
visualization can help us in the other
images that you see here we've had to
play with the size of the Khafre statues
trying to understand based on the floor
emplacements how large or how small the
statue should be or just how big the
platform or base for each one might be
this video shows a reenactment of the
so-called opening of the mouth ceremony
that's the reanimation ceremony for the
deceased King meant to magically and
ritually bring him back to life for the
netherworld we've placed the ceremony
inside Khufu's pyramid temple and again
interesting questions come up when you
do this kind of visualization
now with avatars or human characters so
there ancient Egyptians all over the
scene but how many should there be what
should they be wearing where are the
regular Egyptians are they allowed
anywhere near this ceremony or indeed
anywhere near Giza at all is it daytime
or nighttime did this ceremony even take
place in this temple or in some other
kind of purification tent or temporary
location we've also modelled the faces
on some of these characters after the
ancient Egyptians whose statues were
found nearby in their various tombs so
we have King Jeddah Frey who succeeded
Khufu we have uncuff the Vizier who was
instrumental perhaps in
Khufu and maybe even into cough raised
rain and we have Hemi you know the
architect and engineer who probably
oversaw the construction of the Great
Pyramid itself another aspect of
visualization allows us to dive down a
burial shaft this time we're going to a
plundered burial chamber so not too much
to see but the interesting point here is
that we've chosen to reconstruct the
appearance not in the fourth dynasty not
in antiquity but rather as it looked in
1906 the year that George Reisner and
the excavation team cleared this burial
chamber so it's a plundered room and
first we'll show some photographs of how
it looked in 1906 again a plundered room
just some blocks lying on the floor some
pieces of wood from the coffin some
bones from the burial and there is a
little depression in one corner where
the original canopic jars would have
been located
holding the internal organs of the
deceased as we go into the computer
model now we see that we have
reconstructed everything in beautiful
color just as it was in reissner's
drawings and black-and-white photography
from 1906 no one has been down here
since that time so it's a pretty
accurate and interesting rendering again
you see the blocks on the floor the
pieces of wood the bones and in fact
from these bones which we've located in
a storeroom at Giza and from
inscriptions in a nearby tomb
we've actually been able to identify the
owner of this mastaba she was a woman
named Sadiq
and she's the mother of Mareb who's
beautifully decorated tomb is right next
door and whose Chapel was removed in the
1840s and can now be seen in the Berlin
Noyes Museum the other wonderful thing
about this type of visualization is that
we can come outside of the chamber into
the limestone bedrock if you will and
sort of swim around as no human being
can do and get the underground view of
Giza what I call the tombs eye view so
imagine when all of these hundreds and
hundreds of burial shafts are modeled in
such detail as we see here in the case
of the burial chamber of sadita
where is all this going well new
technologies are coming up all the time
some of them are fantastic some of them
are based on older technologies you're
all familiar with the old
Aereo view cameras and view devices from
the old days
well that's all many of these 360 degree
and panoramic and stereoscopic headsets
are producing for us as well so we'll
carry that further and try to make Giza
ever more accessible we can even start
to recreate the archaeologists
themselves so one day you may be seeing
George Reisner and some of the others
leading you on tours of various areas
around Giza themselves in this example
we're entering a beautifully painted
Chapel of Queen Maris on the third
this was discovered by the Harvard MFA
expedition in 1927 of course in the last
day of work as you'd expect inside were
beautifully preserved wall paintings of
the Queen's Chapel and tourists can
actually visit this tomb today and see
it in all of its glory
normally we couldn't restore all the
colors like this without some guidance
but because the colors remain so
beautifully preserved we have just about
all the information we need in order to
put it back together and finally other
experimentation lets us look at
individual tomb walls click on objects
and have them pop out of the wall in 3d
so you can rotate them around imagine
being able to click on any element a
person a fan a chest a box element of
livestock or craftsmanship and have it
appear in 3d so that you can study it in
more detail these are just some of the
experiments that we're playing with in
our visualization attempts with Giza 3d
where is all of this going possibly
right into your pocket it should be
possible now to serve a Jew tourism to
be able to go to a museum aim your phone
at an object and see the original
discovery or go out to Giza aim your
phone at a lump of mud or a ruined floor
foundation and see the original temple
that once rose there or the location of
a statue that was once found in that
particular location in addition in
recent years colleagues have been
showering the pyramids with cosmic
particle rays Mulan's
in an attempt to locate unknown chambers
and otherwise hidden cavities we're
working on different pathways to allow
you to get into Giza whether you know
everything about the site or nothing
about the site so there should be
something for everyone in our efforts to
make Giza more accessible to the experts
and the amateurs alike and I'll finish
with just this comparison because as we
produce all this material we constantly
think what's going to survive how do we
make this sustainable up above you see a
typical hard drive down below you see a
slab stealer which one of these do you
think we'll still be readable in a few
years
you